was there a particular moment where you
thought
i'm gonna write this book
yes that moment was definitely when i
was around the table with some
colleagues
and we were discussing stop and search
which is
something that's regularly debated
within the media
and i was just sharing my experiences um
and i remember everyone around the table
not actually realizing that i had
experienced it so much and then i gave
an example
of one evening going to 10th downing
street meeting the prime minister
you know being rewarded for my activism
work
and a few days later i ended up in the
back of a police van because i fit a
description
and it was at that point we actually had
a debate and everyone was really
horrified that i had to experience this
but to me it was normal it was something
that happened to me and my friends
so it was at that point i realized that
my reality
or certain people's realities can be
seen as a complete nightmare
to someone who wouldn't have lived
within those experiences
and that was the moment why um i decided
to
write this book which prime minister did
you meet jeremiah i'm david cameron
okay do you think he understood
um what your life was like you said
those people around the table had
no idea of your reality do you think the
pm at the time
understood that nightmare that you were
living in
i think many people don't really
understand a lot of the issues that are
currently happening within the country
maybe it may be due to not enough
conversations happening
maybe it's not being highlighted in the
media this book for me
was really a value in crying and the
opportunity to connect with
young people up around the country who
could you know share their experiences
and stories of
inequalities within education within the
justice system
but what was really important for me
within this book was not only to have
the discussions but really to talk about
solutions
and what we can do to become a more
equal society
well exactly jeremiah in the title what
can we do about it
definitely um that was really really
important for me
um you know especially during this
pandemic we've seen so many forms of
inequality
um you know being brought to the public
at night we saw everything around the
three school meals
um amazing organizations and individuals
like marcus rashford really had to
campaign
for the government to make a u-turn on
their decision on the mata
we've seen issues such as digital
inequality
not long ago i heard of a story of a
family of four
and a mother who was working from home
and her three kids were studying from
home and
they had to share an iphone in between
them and these are real instances that
are affecting
families up around the country and it's
all about having a conversation
i don't blame anyone if they don't
really understand some of these issues
but those in positions of power really
need to take responsibility in tackling
inequality within the uk and do you
think your book
can be the catalyst for that
i definitely hope so for me i
pulled my heart out i had shared my life
story
from beginning till now and really
drawed on my personal
very intimate experiences to really draw
examples of what we can do to create
change within this country jeremiah you
said that
when you were growing up you were quite
literally dreaming in a nightmare if you
could speak
to your younger self what advice would
you give yourself
the advice i would give my younger self
is to continue pushing
but also to let my younger self know
that along the way there's
several different barriers you know
growing up i had to
experience several instances of
prejudice
you know i was i definitely had loads of
opportunities taken away from me
so my message to my younger self would
be to continue going